da ich in diese minecraft episode hier
heute extrem viel arbeit reingesteckt
habe wird es mich mega freuen wenn ihr
dem video einen daumen hoch geben
könnten einen kanal abonnieren würde
wenn ihr weiterhin lok auf solche videos
habt und einfach bis zum ende dran
bleibt also jetzt viel spaß bei
minecraft mit luca ein wunderschöner tag
erwartet uns hier auf unserer mannschaft
fällt meine lieben freunde wenn ihr euch
nicht so anschaut kann man gar nicht
erraten was heute der plan ist wir
entdecken nämlich heute das
piratenschiff und da haben mir wirklich
ganz ganz ganz ganz viel in die
kommentare geschrieben dass ich da
überhaupt keine angst haben brauchen
dort erwarten mich anscheinend nur
einige kisten mit eventuell sogar
irgendwelchen krassen sachen wie
beispielsweise diamanten gold eisen habe
ich da alles gelesen den kommentaren
also danke euch auf jeden fall wieder
für eure zahlreichen tipps ich
bepflanzte ganz kurz mainfeld hier eben
[Musik]
so und bevor wir jetzt wirklich
rübergehen zum piratenschiff habe ich
auch noch einige sachen von euch in den
kommentaren gelesen zum beispiel wurde
mir geschrieben dass ich einen heuballen
unter mein lagerfeuer setzen soll und
dadurch geht der rauch dann noch höher
das heißt wenn wir irgendwann mal
verschollen gehen sollte ist das lager
vorher ja so ein bisschen das woran man
sich orientieren kann also ich setze den
heuballen drunter und das lagerfeuer
geht
[Musik]
doch noch ist gar nicht so dumm wie ihr
ausseht ich setze jetzt trotzdem noch
mal so erde drum dann sieht es
vielleicht ein bisschen schöner aus aber
dann wurde ich ebenfalls von euch daran
erinnert dass der knopf doch bitte sein
comeback feiern soll von daher würde ich
sage packen wir den knopf einfach mal
hier ans lagerfeuer hier vorne und den
kann man jetzt ganz entspannt rücken und
dann wird er nämlich ein witz erzählt
der einzige witz hier bist du
und was sich ebenfalls noch in den
kommentaren gelesen habe war dass ich
mir doch einen komposter mal machen
sollte macht man so und dann hat man
einen komposter also ich setze jetzt mal
irgendwie so hierhin beispielsweise
jetzt kann ich mir meine ganze
weizenkörner reinpacken von den ich ja
wirklich unglaublich viele habe und da
bekomme ich jetzt bei mir aus ich habe
dann ein halbes deck weitere
eingeschmissen wow
danke für eure tipps leute warum ist ja
eigentlich zur geisteskrank viel
lautstärke immer
die höhle habe ich hier was zu gebaut
[Musik]
okay okay ich das euch davor einfach ein
bisschen chillen da müssen wir die tage
auch noch ein ich hab mich gefragt warum
das gras hier vorne so tillich entspannt
darauf wächst hier vorne allerdings gar
nicht und da wurde mir die kommentare
geschrieben dass das ein licht level
lied von daher hab ich mir gedacht bei
euch hier vorne jetzt ein dass text doch
hier hoch ich werde nun hier vorne jetzt
erstmal meine blumen drauf setzen so
dann haben wir hier 1 2345 hier kommen
dann auch die eichenholz fallschirm noch
daran die forderung die ecke plötzlich
da nämlich einfach diese eichenholz
meter das ist vielleicht auch ganz schön
aus und dann haben wir jetzt von außen
eine ja kann man schon sagen dann wurde
mir auch noch unten die kommentare
geschrieben und zwar dass sich doch die
laternen einfach mit ketten an die bäume
hängen kann dann sieht das ganze
vielleicht noch ein bisschen schöner aus
und wir haben hier nicht überall diese
komischen pümpel rumstehen dann setzen
wir vorne noch eine laterne daran mit
einer kette hängt dann irgendwie hier so
runter wollte ich generell mal weg
nehmen die wollte ich nämlich zu stein
ziegelstein ziegelmauern finde ich da
wirklich deutlich schöner kann man
nämlich dann einfach so machen das sieht
ein bisschen edler ausfindig ans grab
von der crew könnten wir theoretisch
einfach auch mal anstatt diese blöden
fackeln an der seite einfach oben drauf
sondern laterne setzen ich finde
laternen generell so ein bisschen den
edlen look dann machen wir hier die
fackel an der seite auch noch ab hier
die stein ziegel wieder abbauen
es wird auch schon wieder verdammt
nochmal nacht in einer minute dreißig
und wir waren noch einmal auf dem
piratenschiff ich gerne schnell schlafen
und ich verspreche euch bevor das
nächste mal die sonne untergeht sind wir
auf dem piratenschiff
also bleibt dran abonniert schauen wir
mal den kanal als das nicht getan habt
ihr könnt euch jederzeit umentscheiden
aber das sollte man eigentlich besser
nicht tun hier vorne und hier wollte ich
auch noch so stein zu mauern hinmachen
mit laternen drauf dann wurde mir halt
für hier geschrieben dass sich eine axt
[Musik]
ich habe hände aus stahl mir wird sehr
häufig geschrieben dass ich mir kein
schwert machen soll mit den diamanten
nicht gefunden habe sondern eine axt
weil die angeblich mehr schaden macht
jedoch ist die angriffs geschwindigkeit
geringer also wir können wieder gerne in
die kommentare schreiben was ihr davon
ich habe jetzt ein lagerfeuer zu wenig
rabatt
und jetzt kann ich das auch zu machen
sondern sieht aus wie ein weg als sie
deutlich kleiner aus als vorher ich bin
ready für das piratenschiff meine lieben
freunde hier vor uns jetzt unser stieg
das sieht schon schön aus unsere kleine
insel von daher davor dahin landmann das
haller waldmanns heil volle see voraus
meine lieben freunde 70 knoten ab in
richtung piratenschiff ich habe mich
extra ist ein bisschen vorbereitet
bisschen eingelesen da stand wirklich
dass da uns überhaupt keinen gefahren
erwarten also sollte ziemlich langweilig
werden richtig geil wäre halt wenn da
vorne jetzt einfach dingens wäre wenn
ihr diamanten liegen würden oder so von
daher flächen uns einfach mal an dass
das hier so sand
ok wenn wir auf fichtenstamm türen die
seen sogar noch besser aus für unsere
für unser kleines blumenbeete namens
vaters und des sohnes und des heiligen
geistes armen
ich wünsche mir dass dort diamanten drin
sind der moment der wahrheit
meine lieben freunde
lederjacke sieht da war schon fischen
aus ein paar sekunden später
wieso kann ich nicht mehr wegnehmen
leute habe ich irgendwas ich kriege ich
nicht weg das habe ich ja schon wieder
falsch gemacht wir haben auf jeden fall
auch noch einiges an papier drin wir
haben weizen drin das forderte fleisch
brauchen wir nicht karotten sind sehr
wichtigen uns im roten feld machen
papier nämlich alle mit die kiste
nämlich auch mit kann man immer
gebrauchen in dem auch noch den stamm
mit
das ist echt interessant ja im namen des
vaters und des sohnes und des heiligen
geistes armen alle zuhause bitte auch
mit beeten bitte da sind diamanten drin
papier dann bücher ohne karten
[Musik]
wir haben eine schatzkarte
doch die kiste im namen des vaters und
des sohnes und des heiligen geistes
armen da fällt mir direkt der hut vom
kopf bitte da sind diamanten drin was
ist das meeres guten
ich habe ein bisschen schiss
bin ich ganz ehrlich wir fahren hier in
tiefster nacht über waren auch schneller
rückwärts ich lass das boot da vorne
jetzt einfach mal stehen
das kann nicht sein alter da werden
wieder gabeln auf mich geworfen
adam ich jetzt absolut gar keinen bock
drauf da habe ich keine nerven ich gehe
jetzt einfach auf gut glück ich jetzt
auch nicht auf einfach dass er keine
monster sind so ganz schnell jetzt
irgendwie anders männer aus und jetzt
mit wurden auch kommentare geschrieben
das ist wohl einer der stärksten mops in
minecraft stellt mich auf mein bett
besucht ja nicht du ja das freut mich
für dich ja wir könnten unsere
schatzkarte angucken
doch dies auf der insel nebenan schnauze
schreib mir gerade eine e mail die sonne
geht auf meine lieben freunde und das
heißt dass die ganzen monster hier jetzt
sterben werden
was wir sehr typ ist ein gabel die
verstecken sich auch
rüdiger veil dass wir hier so viel
stress immer mit mit gegnern haben
ediger alter macht er viel schaden wie
kann er denn so krass sein wenn der typ
kommt bin ich auf jeden fall ready wir
sind jetzt allerdings erst mal auf
unserer kleinen insel die angekommen
denn hier soll angeblichen schatz seien
nämlich genau hier vorne
[Musik]
ok
das ist höchst interessant es war so
klein ist der schatz und schwefel
warum genau hier genau da ist er ist der
schatz und dazu das war's jetzt oder wie
[Musik]
einfach der profi der gab
ganz vorsichtig büchern mit niemandem
irgendwie irgendwie streit anfangen
möchte einfach nur den schatz finden
ich weiß nicht woher diese 7000 krieg
haben ob ihr ins bonner ist und das soll
der start sei aber dann müsste hier auch
ein spanner angezeigt werden
stattdessen haben wir hier nicht stehen
jetzt allerdings trotzdem er jedoch dass
redstone mit das können wir mal ganz gut
gebrauchen ich habe auch einige
kommentare gelesen dass ich doch wenn
ich neue inseln entdecke mir mal so
verbindungen bauen soll wird
beispielsweise mein card strecken
da habe ich auf jeden fall auch bock
drauf die sache ist nur dass sich jetzt
gerade erst mal den schatz hier finden
möchte und ich weiß nicht ob das gegen
die nur ein job war mit dieser
schatzkarte aber es ist ja genau hier
also das hier ist ja der ort ich kann ja
nochmal drauf gucken hier wir sind genau
da wartet stoffen hier genau hier soll
der schatz sein
das einzige was hier passiert ist es
dass ein krieg explodiertes und ich bin
gestorben
was für eine pure enttäuschung ihre
diese schatzkarte sollte lieber scheiß
karte heißen sommer der liebe freunde
ich habe mir früher noch mal kurz die
farben angeschmissen und bepflanzt das
jetzt alles mal neu an der stelle wo ich
die heutige episode jetzt auch beenden
wir haben ganz ganz viel geschafft wir
sind zum piratenschiff gefahren wir
haben das mit der schatzkarte
ausprobiert ich habe den heuballen
runter gesetz werden das mit den
laternen hier gemacht das sieht echt
schön aus wie vor das natürlich ein
kripperl auch das müssen wir noch
ausbessern demnächst wir haben das mit
unserem kleinen blumenbeet haben wir
hinbekommen das sieht man jetzt hier
hier vorne haben wir die eichenholz
weiterhin gefragt es war eine produktive
folge
allerdings sind wir auch mal wieder
gestorben scheidet in der nächsten folge
minecraft mit luca wieder ein wenn es
heißt wir machen die große bootstour
[Musik]